shane on the year
he is five and three he's a 313 earned
run average as you mentioned 110
strikeouts in his 72 innings
he has walked 27. he's given up nine
home runs but
he's coming in he's 2-0 against the
white sox
swing and a miss he went fishing and
came up empty
bieber gets his first strikeout his 11th
start of the year he's three and one as
e.r.a
spectacular 298. 66 strikeouts and 51 on
the third he's only walked 26.
and so the indians have runners at first
and third
and josh naylor the banner there goes
eddie rosario
and it gets by the pitcher tim anderson
will have to hurry naylor beats it out
and the indians
take a one-nothing lead put the ball in
play and maybe something good will
happen
he didn't hit it hard but he squibbed it
past the pitcher's mount and tim
anderson had the old do or die
play and an awfully tough play it'll be
an infield single the indians will jump
up top and take a one-nothing lead for
naylor's 15th ribby
you better capitalize with a guy as good
as dylan
cease you may not get another
opportunity like this
harold ramirez off the glove anderson
again has a do or die play and ramirez
beats it out
how do you like that back-to-back
infield hits and the indians have a
two-to-nothing lead
i'll tell you cease put got a glove on
it and it knocked it down and
maybe if he let that ball go they would
have been able to get ramirez at first
to the left vaughn did he get there
andrew vaughan down to the grass to haul
in the final out
just an outstanding effort and it's it's
one that you don't see very often from
established left fielders he's just
learning the position he charges it
one and two on collins the kick and the
pitch and there's a soft liner for a
base hit to center
lamb has a play right in front of him
and he's going to hold it second
nice job keep the line moving this is a
big at bat for the socks here
here's billy hamilton hitting 230.
some big hits here of late billy
hamilton gives this a ride to right
field naylor's back he
is not going to get there it's off the
base of the wall
lamb's coming home here comes the second
one with collins he is safe
ball gets away billy's safe oh he's
always wanted the inside the parker
and he got home as the ball trickled
away from the plate
billy hamilton sprinting home makes it
3-2
socks it was a great play at the plate i
don't think it's an inside the parker
because the ball
got away from hedges both runners going
and billy hamilton
is flying there's a throw to the plate
safe at the plate a good slide now watch
this the ball gets away
back of the plate bieber can't get him
billy the hitter needs a cut man look at
look at his lip and his nose
cease oh my goodness look what i found
out number three hardest hit fall of the
night
jose ramirez will lead off the bottom of
the third ramirez with a drive into deep
right center field
this will short hop the wall ramirez on
his way to second
and he's him standing with his 11th two
bagger
another rocket off the bat of jose
ramirez
harold ramirez an rbi single on an
infield hit in the first inning
and a line drive base in left field big
harold ties the game at three
what'd we talk about a little easier to
get a ball upstairs at spinning
and he left this breaking ball so the
indians get a two-strike hit now
and they tie the ball game harold gets
his ninth rbi
but that's i mean you go out there you
need the starts you got to work
broken bat that's going to get down for
a hit boy the barrel ended up almost in
one of the dugout suites behind home
plate
hit high on the screen and bounced back
hedges in these spots
has been productive in moving runners as
cease
sets at the belt here's his pitch swung
on and there's a high fly ball to left
it's deep back on it is vaughn he's
looking up
homerun hedges onto the porch
and the indians take the lead 5-3
but again another hitter working the
count full and finally hedges
got a pitch that he could handle a
slider that was up
and austin hedges has hit his third home
run on the season
to put the tribe in front jose ramirez
one for two tonight a double and a run
scored
swung on line drive center field that
gets down for a base hit
tailing toward the gap and left center
on his way to third is rosario
he's not stopping there on his way home
and he will score
and into second with a hustle double
that drives in another run
jose ramirez indians now lead it
six to three year mean mercedes the
batter tribe up six to three
sox batting sixth ending bases empty
mercedes sends one
high in the air to deep left ramirez is
back on the track near the wall he leaps
and
he made the catch harold ramirez having
a big night
a leaping grab at the wall and left to
take
extra bases away from mercedes
and hopefully more the same tonight
bunt popped up ryan byrne lays out oh
goodness gracious ryan he's hurt i hope
he's all right
ryan burr goes sprawling for a catch
for route number one
swinging in a miss held onto the foul
tip did hedges and that strikeout
number six for shane bieber there's the
curveball coming back and a dandy
got a piece of it right into the glove
of hedges
[Music]
[Applause]
he tried to hold him but he went around
chased it and bieber gets his seventh
strikeout of the night stretch time
with the indians on top 6-3
8th inning tying run at the plate for
chicago as brian shaw delivers
swing and a miss he struck him out
mercedes offensive utility has
reached 0 for his last 19.
slam first and jake lamb
squares him up for a base hit to right
field
[Music]
boy what a night it's been for jake he's
been on base four times a couple of
walks couple of base hits
one and two for collins
zach loops it to left field that's a
base hit lamb's coming home
this is six to four and the tying run
walks up to the plate
here in the ninth inning the sox again
score on karen jack
madrigal 0 for four reached on an error
in the third
ground ball base hit center field
collins will score
anderson trying to make 30 better hurry
he is
safe and by doing that he allows
madrigal on that throw to third to reach
second
it's a one-run game the tying run at
third the go-ahead run at second
boy that that is a gutsy maneuver
by tim anderson but it worked out
now there's no room for anything or
anybody
two down in the night a one-run indians
lead
jose abreu over four tonight
but he can be the hero for chicago now
ground ball to short rosario throws
book it
life